[Musique]
les essentielles du sénat
mineurs non accompagnés
quarante propositions pour une politique
nationale
entre 2014 et 2017 le nombre de mineurs
non accompagnés bénéficiant des
dispositifs de protection de l'enfance a
triplé passant de 5000 33 à 17 milles 22
il s'agit d'un enjeu majeur pour les
départements qui doivent procéder à une
évaluation sociale des demandeurs et
mettre en place un accueil provisoire
d'urgence
dans ce contexte les sénateurs hussein
bourgi laurent burgoa xavier iacovelli
et henri leroy appel dans un rapport
d'information à structurer la prise en
charge des mineurs non accompagnés à
travers une véritable politique
nationale
dans leur travail présenté le 29
septembre 2021 les sénateurs examinent
avant tout la question de la régulation
des flux et de l'entrée dans le
dispositif d'accueil
il relève que le suivi des mineurs non
accompagnés souffre d'un manque de
moyens juridiques et financiers ainsi
que d'un défaut de cohérence à l'échelle
du territoire
face au coût annuel de la prise en
charge des mineurs non accompagnés par
l'aide sociale à l'enfance l'aide
sociale à l'enfance estimé à environ 1,1
milliard d'euros les rapporteurs plaide
pour le transfert à l'état de
l'évaluation et de la mise à l'abri
le rapport aborde également les
problématiques de sécurité posés par
certains jeunes isolés
en rencontrant des acteurs de terrain la
mission d'information a établi qu'une
très grande majorité des faits de
délinquance commis par des mineurs
étrangers ou des personnes se présentant
comme tels ne sont pas le fait de
mineurs non accompagnés pris en charge
par l'aide sociale à l'enfance mais de
jeunes en errance
cette délinquance ne concerne plus les
seuls centres villes des grandes
communes mais tend à se propager aux
communes périphériques
pour y remédier les sénateurs suggèrent
notamment de renforcer la présence et
les pouvoirs de la police et de la
gendarmerie dans les transports
il préconise aussi d'ouvrir aux forces
de sécurité l'accès aux données
contenues dans le traitement d'appui à
l'évaluation de la minorité
et il plaide pour la création d'un
fichier national des mineurs non
accompagnés délinquants
enfin le rapport se penche sur la
préparation de la sortie de minorité des
jeunes pris en charge
une scolarisation effective tout au long
de la prise en charge par l'aide sociale
à l'enfance qui permet aux jeunes
d'acquérir la maîtrise du français
apparaît comme une condition essentielle
de l'accès à l'autonomie des mineurs non
accompagnés
pour en savoir plus consultez la
synthèse du rapport
[Musique]